we're told that a train traveling
through japan has 90 passengers
52 passengers get off in tokyo
in kobe
another 29 passengers get off the train
no new passengers get on the train
and then they ask us how many passengers
are still on the train
pause this video and see if you can work
through that before we work on this
together
all right now let's do this together so
first what we could think about is how
many total passengers there are and then
the nut to figure out how many are left
well you have to start with your total
take away 52 that get off in tokyo then
take away another 29 then get off in
kobe and then however many you have left
that's how many are still on the train
and we can imagine that with a tape
diagram
so let's say that the length of this
tape or the length of this rectangle
represents the initial the starting 90
passengers so that's 90
passengers
and then how many get off in tokyo 52
and i'm doing this so that you we can
visualize it so we can think about what
it looks like so we'll take away 52
which might be something like this
so 52
off
in
tokyo
tokyo and then we have another 29
passengers that get off the train in
kobe
so then another 29 maybe that's
something like this
get off in kobe
so 29
off
in
kobe and so how many passengers are
still left well if you start with 90 52
get off in tokyo 29 get off in kobe then
this last part of the length of the tape
that would be how many are left so right
over there
this is the
how many how
many
how many left
would be the length of this red part of
the tape because we've taken off the 52
and the 29 off of the 90.
so to figure that out we could first try
to figure out what is 90
minus 52. if you haven't figured that
out you could pause the video and try to
figure that out
all right well one way to think about it
90 minus 52 is the same thing as 90
minus 50 minus 2. so i could write it
this way minus 50
minus 2
and you might recognize that 90 minus
fifty that's nine tens minus five tens
that's going to be four tens this is
going to be forty so this is going to be
forty
minus two and then two less than forty
well that's going to be thirty eight
so this is going to be equal to 38.
so if you only had that one stop after
that first stop you have 38 passengers
left on the train and so that 38 is this
amount right over here
but then we know another 29 get off in
kobe so we need to start with that 38
and 29 are going to get off so minus 29
and we can view this as maybe we could
rewrite this this is equal to 30
plus 8 that's 38 and we're going to
subtract 20 and 9. so subtract 20 and
subtract 9. this wouldn't be subtract 20
then add 9 that wouldn't be 29. we're
subtracting
2 tens and 9 ones so we're subtracting
20 and nine
so first we could view this as 30
minus 20 which is going to be 10
and then we're going to
add 8 and then subtract 9
subtract 9. now what is 10 plus 8
10 plus 8 we know is 18.
now if we subtract 9 from 18 you might
already know that that's going to be 9
another way to think about it if you
subtract 8 from 18 you're going to be
just left with 10 and then you have one
more to take away so you're going to be
left with nine
so we are going to have
nine passengers left on the train start
with 90 52 get off there's 38 left then
another 29 get off now we have 9 left